those those of you don't know me my name
is Tom Dolan
um and uh we do have a quorum
a quorum equals six of us
committee members and we we exceed that
we're going to miss
I already know Fred Doucette won't be
able to make it today as a conflict
and I don't know about representative
walls if
if that spot would be filled but we're
we're ready to go
thank you Mr chairman thank you
honorable committee members we are very
thankful for this opportunity to present
to you today my name is Deborah Childs
and I'm the deputy chief of staff for
the house and I'm joined by my peers
other staff members who represent
different areas and Departments of the
commission process can you hear me okay
yep okay
all right
so we're going to start off with the
charge of the committee and then the
staff is going to walk through the
commission process each of us will you
know walk through our process for our
area and then we're going to talk about
challenges and Improvement opportunities
Improvement opportunities that have
already been implemented things that are
in progress and then potentially some
recommendations that you can consider
and then we'll open it up to q a so if
we may we ask that you hold your
questions to the end unless it's a
clarification question otherwise if you
have a question just jot it down because
we may answer it throughout the
presentation
then at the end next steps we have a
couple next steps that we'll talk about
what we're doing from a staff
perspective and then each one of you
will receive a binder we have a lot of
supporting documentation to some of the
points that we're going to bring up
today it's not my binder representative
patuchek but uh it's a binder with a lot
of documentation that will be helpful
including a draft list of all of these
statutory commissions
so to start off
um just bear with me for a moment
because the next two slides I I am going
to read it because it's very important
context for the whole presentation
the first is the problem statement you
can see up on the screen
over the past several decades there's
been an ever increasing number of
legislative committees commissions
boards councils task forces and working
groups in recent years more are created
each year than are repealed some are
duplicative covering overlapping subject
matter even overlapping in their
membership whereas others don't meet or
take any action at all
many have limited to no accountability
and therefore do not fulfill their
statutory requirements for appointments
deadlines reporting Etc
there's no consistent methodology when
new commissions are created and the
process for creating appointing managing
and maintaining them is complex and
extremely time consuming for both
legislators and staff
the sheer number of commissions alone
prevents legislators and staff from
making their way through the process in
a timely and efficient manner and it
takes them away from other work
including focusing on the commissions
which are active and productive
and then for the committee charge
there is hereby established a special
committee on commissions it shall be the
duty of the committee on commissions to
consider all matters pertaining to
legislative statutory committees
commissions subcommittees ad hoc boards
councils task forces and working groups
the committee is to review and evaluate
related processes and identify any
issues inconsistencies root causes and
possible solutions to make improvements
while also helping to decrease the
number of statutory commissions overall
and going forward
the committee can consider but not limit
themselves to considering the following
review commissions which could be
Consolidated or repealed review related
processes Administration and relevant
statutes including reporting
requirements
consider opportunities for
accountability and improving enforcement
improve the standards for writing
legislation related to commissions
consider standardizing the process for
reviewing bills related to commissions
propose enabling legislation to enforce
these improvements
and help communicate knowledge and
improvements to colleagues and other
stakeholders
so that's our problem statement and our
committee charge and we are honored to
have the speaker of the house with us
who's going to say a few additional
words related to the charge
very few
this staff has done such a phenomenal
job putting this together that uh
there's not a heck of a lot I can add to
it except most of you know
how much I hate some of these things
and I think it's just as super waste of
time and I know representative evil has
been working on this for a long time
um we have too many
I think last last year we
got rid of 22 or 23 and we passed 60 new
ones
uh it it just it just keeps escalating
and it doesn't make any sense and
um I know all of you make so much money
you just love to come up here for a
commission that doesn't do anything and
we have too many of those that don't do
anything don't meet we found one that
was in existence for a year and a half
and hadn't even have the members
appointed to it
and then we also found many that
especially on Health and Human Services
that overlapped
that could be combined into one
Commission
so our goal here is is
basically what uh Miss Childs pointed
out to you is let's see if we can fix
this
and I'm confident that we can fix it so
that um
we can have commissions that actually do
something and actually put forth a
report that means something and when it
comes to legislation if that's what's
requested of it we have something to go
forward with
um
I think you have a daunting task ahead
of you because there is so much that you
really need to look over and
um but
um I would just ask that uh let's see if
we can
help future legislators from going
through what we've had to go through for
too many years now
with that I'll turn it back to the
experts
thank you Mr Speaker
all right so now we're going to get into
the presentation starting with the
commission process and each one of us
will go through introduce our introduce
ourselves the area that we work with and
then talk about our process
warning uh my name is Jim CNC I'm house
legal counsel uh my piece of this
presentation is to give sort of an
overview of RSA 1449 which is the
statute which defines legislative study
committees and commissions I'll also
talk a little bit about uh amendments to
that statute which occurred in 2022
which was sort of a first attempt to
curtail some of these things and then
also talk about a current bill which the
Senate has passed Senate Bill 84 which
is currently in the house which may make
further changes to the statute so I
think I'll start with talking about
um a very brief overview of 1449
um
you can think of it in terms of defining
three types of entities two of which
really aren't a problem but I'll talk
about them anyways uh the first are what
are called chaptered studies and these
are studies which exist only in chapter
law they are not codified in statute
which means that they're temporary they
are the membership is limited to
legislators only traditionally it's
usually three house four house members
one Senate member you can almost think
of them in terms of a subcommittee of a
house standing committee they exist only
for the biennium so if they're
established in the first year of the
biennium they usually if they have
reporting deadline of that year they go
away after that first year or at a
maximum they only exist for the full two
for the for the two years
um and the other important piece is
these are staffed by if they're a house
study they're staffed by house staff so
they're really not an issue because
they're very similar to what we are
already have within the outstanding
committees in terms of structure the
other type of committee which really
isn't an issue but I want to mention it
is and there's no real specific term
form I refer to them as regulatory
entities these are established by
Statute and they perform either an
administrative or regulatory function
and they have a Perpetual term
and they're not established for study
purposes a couple of examples they could
be legislator only
um like the fiscal committee gel car is
another one there are about I want to
say 10 to 12 that are legislator only
and obviously those are staffed by the
legislature usually LBA or
um uh
thank you
um and then there's others that are I
use the Board of Medicine as an example
where their executive branch and their
staff by the executive branch there may
be legislators on them but they're
really not a legislative study
and so they're really not an issue as
well and the other important thing is
these types of entities usually have
very specific rules of procedure because
they perform an administrative or
regulatory function so they're almost in
many ways like an executive branch
agency in that in that aspect
so what we're we're really talking about
when we're talking about study
commissions are everything else and
um in terms of definition their
statutory entities so they are
establishing statute for a purpose for
the purpose of studying a specific uh
topic
um they may include a term and they may
not many of the ones that are currently
in statute never established a term I
think of the committee to study Exotic
Aquatic weeds is one of those it's been
Perpetual for over 20 years because
there was never a term established for
that
um these they do include legislators but
usually the majority of the membership
are non-legislators and that can include
the the chair of the committee and then
in terms of Staffing it's it's sort of a
hybrid some are staffed by the
legislature some are not and you'll hear
later about some of the issues that that
presents
um but and also in terms of where they
meet as well some meet
in in the State House complex some don't
and so they present a host of challenges
um due to their nature
um so in terms of of the 2022 amendments
and representative evil obviously knows
this because she was a co-sponsor of the
bill
um it was an attempt to sort of further
Define these study commissions uh
provide uh you know more more structure
to them and so what what uh what the
Amendments did was it um first of all it
required the commission term to be
specified so you couldn't leave it it no
longer open-ended
um and then the statutory authorization
shall be repealed no later than five
years after the effective date unless it
was subsequently reauthorized by Statute
so in other words the most you could
have would be a five-year term unless
you came in later to reauthorize it
um the membership was limited to 15
members total and which could include
non-legislators but the legislative
members had to constitute a majority of
the commission and this was an attempt
to curtail some of uh there are some
study commissions out there with 20 plus
members
which may have included only one or two
legislative numbers so that specifically
addressed that issue and then also the
uh the legislator term legislative term
members on the commission also was
co-terminous with their term in office
because there are other issues that
where you had a member who was no longer
a member of the house or Senate who is
still on the body and the question was
were they still allowed to be on that
this sort of tightened that up to say
that you know your term on the on this
study commission is coterminous with
your German office
um so and we're still sort of we've had
sort of offline discussions of how how
much effect these Amendments have had on
the new commissions moving forward
um and it's still sort of up in the air
I mean it's it's there are attempts
we've heard to sort of go around the
requirements of the statute
um but we it's still sort of unclear in
the effect and it's only been in effect
for about a year anyways
um so the new development is Senate bill
84. um this started as a study
commission to study I believe is a
taxation issue and the Senate
um essentially uh amended the entire
Bill
and replaced it with a repeal and
reenactment of RSA 1449 and what it
would do is it would separate out the
two statutes so 1449 would only Define
chaptered studies and then it would
um enact a new RSA 1449-a relative to
study commissions so you'd have two
separate statutes
and what it does is it takes the
15-member limit which was established
last year last year for study
commissions and then it would apply it
to the chaptered studies I'm not sure
the reason for that because chapter
studies usually only have five members
or so so that was for whatever reason
they took it out of the commission
portion and added it to the to the
chaptered study and so what it would do
for the legislative study commissions it
deletes that 15 member limit and also
the legislator majority provision as
well but it does add a a provision and
this is something that I talked with my
colleague in the senate about it would
require that all commissions shall be
administratively attached to the
appropriate executive branch agency as
determined by the general court so
essentially what it would require is if
you establish a if the legislature were
to establish a study commission with
outside members it would all the
legislation would also have to specify
which executive branch agency would be
responsible for that in terms of hosting
it Staffing it uh and whatnot
um that bill did pass the Senate it is
now in possession of uh legislative
Administration and um let's see how that
goes moving forward so that's really all
I have in terms of the overview on the
statute and we'll talk a little bit
later about some of the issues with the
statute but that's uh that's sort of
what I have
thank you Jim I'm Dave alaconis the
director of legislative services and uh
as you know we're kind of the first step
in the process of uh creating these
things our members
come in and uh
and start the process usually it's by
it's almost entirely by email now which
is a bit of a
a problem and that we've moved to the
online and paperless because we have
less face-to-face interaction but that
is the nature of where we're moving in
in society with everything
but we don't have a while we don't have
a true checklist when we're forming
commissions it's kind of built into the
system I don't want to get to inside a
baseball-ish regarding our legislative
management system the software that we
use that tracks a bill from beginning to
end uh but we have when we're drafting
in the in that system there macros so
certain boilerplate language does uh
does pop up we can choose it and that's
uh that's generally how how it works if
a request is duplicative we will try we
will talk to the requesting member uh
try to discourage or dissuade
however it's our experience that uh when
when our member of the legislature comes
in and requests us a commission
that comes in
at the jump at the very front end of it
and that they've got their mind made up
already so that can create problems
because sometimes it's not a boilerplate
you know we've heard about working
groups and task forces and names being
changed so that they're not commissions
but there are commissions uh and we get
names of organizations that are
requested to provide a member
that sometimes don't even exist their
their name of we don't
check to see if that organization really
exists
it's one thing if it's the Bia or
something that's a group that we all
know but there are a lot of very obscure
organizations that get uh membership on
on some of these commissions
and of course confidentiality uh
everything that is done at OLS until a
bill is introduced or until an amendment
is put on the table in one of the
committee rooms is uh confidential work
between uh OLS and the requesting member
so while the the requesting member May
uh
distribute it and talk about the
proposal we really can't do that and we
never know when uh when something is put
on the table and I point out that we at
this time of year we're always being
asked for certain amendments and we
don't know when you as members put that
Amendment on the table where it's
offered so we can't even
we can't uh answer those requests to uh
to provide amendments uh
because we don't know what what stage of
the process it's in
now of this year and now this is these
numbers are a little over a week old but
there were somewhere around 45 bills uh
that have create
commissions or adjust commissions
and uh again the vast majority of those
3738 came in as an initial request of
the member when we were drafting back in
the fall
we have I believe seven that I counted
seven that were created via an amendment
uh during the process this year and I'm
not saying that these bills are that
they've gone forward or not uh I just
did a search of commissions and whether
it's an amendment uh or if it's in uh
the main the bill is introduced
and
there were a number of amendments
creating commissions just last week I
know that we we drafted so I don't know
what they are but uh the number of them
were created that way
and that's our process from the from the
beginning uh that it of course goes
through
the rest of the house in the Senate and
eventually back to us for enrolling and
sending up to the governor
foreign thank you
good morning everyone uh Paul Smith
Clerk of the house
um again like Jim I'm just sort of going
to give you an overview of the clerk's
office process for now and then we'll
sort of talk about more of the
nitty-gritty dirty details later
so the clerk's office is responsible for
the review of all house bills and
determining if there is a statutory
study committee or commission that has
been established by our bills this view
has historically been a combing through
of all the legislation as it becomes
chapter law because as Dave said
we often even though a bill might not
have been drafted as a committee or
commission it may have been turned into
one and this is something that we often
find that if if a sponsor doesn't feel
like he may or he or she may have the
votes then let's turn it into a study
and we can study it and then we can
introduce a bill in the second year but
I would also remind you that our house
rules do prohibit that that if a bill is
made subject of a study in the first
year it does have to require a rule
suspension or going through rules
committee to introduce separately and
that is that is something that has
historically been
sort of upsetting to some folks anyway
um so the painstaking process begins of
compiling the information while actively
identifying the appropriate contact
person or persons for the notification
of their appointment
and as Dave said I do want to stress
that this can sometimes be a difficult
task as members may have misidentified
organization during the Bill's drafting
or in some cases I.E in the naming of
somebody like the Seabrook power plant
where a local designee could not readily
be appointed due to lack of information
fortunately a month or two after that
the lobbyist contacted us who
represented that organization and we
were able to finally work on who to
identify
in some instances members who have
shepherded commissions through the law
making process may be over eager to have
folks appointed before the law has even
been signed by the governor
our former member from stratum was
Notorious for that
um
so while the process of communication is
happening with external forces it's also
happening internally as well the
speaker's office the Senate president's
office and the governor's office are all
notified and in your binders later you
will see a notif a sample notification
email that goes out from my office
so we create the committee or Commission
in our legislative management Suite that
powers all the data that's available on
the website we take the contact
information and are mindful of the term
length if stipulated and sort of
according to the position in which they
are numerated in the legislation
I often do hear from the first name
member inquiring if a quorum has yet to
be appointed if less than a quorum has
not been appointed it's not legal to
call a meeting
if a quorum has been appointed the first
name member May schedule a meeting that
being said a quorum must be present to
make the meeting in any actions there at
legal
lastly pursuant to the changes made in
RSA 1449 last year the clerks of the
respective body shall then send a copy
of the report to the standing committee
of each body with jurisdiction over the
subject matter
and again
um I I would just mention too that that
oftentimes you do have bills that did
not start out as studies that have been
turned into studies and and those are
harder to keep track of
um but we do we have sort of identified
and we'll talk about this a little more
later some of those internal workings to
help that process
foreign
thank you
all right the next part in the process
is the appointing authority chooses
appointees for each of the commissions
and again I'm Deborah I work for the
speaker of the house so the speaker has
to make appointments to the commissions
now I have my own spreadsheet and
um most appointing authorities have
their own spreadsheet which lists all of
the commissions and we search we sort
that by term end date because when a
term is ending we need to know the next
appointment is due
and then I also if I can lift this
have my binder
no props
[Laughter]
so these are all of the statutory
commissions as you can see in the in the
photo on the slide deck I have two other
binders because one of them is for other
committees and commissions like our our
policy committees committees created by
executive orders by the governor ad hocs
and all those these are statutory
committees alone
and so if if a new commission is created
there's a little bit of a separate
process and I and I have a binder to
keep those in so if we pass 65 in a year
they're not yet we don't yet have the
RSA and so I keep them in a separate
separate file but
um to be notified of a new commission I
can get this from various methods and
ways I may have one of the clerk's
office inform me that there's a new
commission I may have a member because
they have interest in the commission I
may hear it on the news that a new
commission was created so I work to
collect all those new commissions so the
speaker can make his appointments
then I review the RSA the RSA
specifically the um
commission requirements because lots of
times they have requirements you have to
appoint the speaker has to appoint maybe
two members who are or are on the
Judiciary Committee for example one
who's on C you know criminal justice
um perhaps one from the minority and one
from the majority so there's a lot of
specific requirements and that's why I
have my binder which I have my
spreadsheet and then this supports that
this is all sorted by RSA so I can flip
to the RSA and make sure the speaker is
is well informed of what the
requirements are and then also in this
binder I have notes because lots of
times there's back and forth in this
process I may have recommendations from
chairs or the speaker may ask that I
follow up with the member to make sure
they have interest expertise and the
capacity to be able to take on the
position it's not just we have 400
members so just to point someone it's
it's a process we want to make sure we
appoint the right people to each
committee
so then the speaker speaker makes the
decision and then I send out an
appointment notice and I update my
spreadsheet
other parts of the process that the
speaker's office follows is we approve
mileage for committee members to to go
to the state department you know the
particular State Department or to the
state house and then also
um generally at the end of the year the
speaker receives a copy of uh the the
reports interim reports and final
reports that come out of these
commissions and that presumably is is my
role here however I do receive a lot of
commission questions and then meeting
with every other department here we
receive a lot of the same questions
um and a lot of it is because of the you
know the sheer number and the you know
the confusion from the sheer numbers so
we receive a lot of the same questions
that takes up a lot of Staff time and
legislator time as well
that's pretty much my process and moving
on to the next
good morning everybody
I'm Ann Fitzgerald and I'm the director
of Health Community Services and it is
our office who supports these study
commissions administratively and also
with research staff and I have a lot to
say but I'll do it on the second round
the first round I'm just going to go
over
um our our process as everyone has been
doing just to give you a quick overview
so once the first named member
um is named they will hopefully come to
us to schedule their organization
meeting but one of the things we have to
do is constantly monitor as
representative Dolan did this morning we
have to keep monitoring to see uh on the
web page if a um a quorum has been
achieved yet and that can take time and
some we've had some members who want us
to con to monitor it regularly but we
don't have the staff to do that so uh we
have to achieve that before we can
schedule their organizational meeting we
also have an instruction sheet that
explains to the first name what their
role is and what they need to do to make
that meeting happen and to move forward
what the chair needs to do the committee
assistants support these commissions
clerically we don't take minutes but we
as I mentioned scheduled the meetings
maintain the files and we type their
minutes for the myth they're handwritten
the researchers whose staff the
commissions uh usually or they monitor
them if they're staffed by an agency
it's usually wherever the bill
originated in the house whatever
committee that came out of the
researcher was assigned to that standing
committee usually takes on this study
commission as well
um and the chair is elected at the first
meeting again if the Quorum exists and
we start working with the chair after
that the chair will appoint a clerk
and then we also have we assist with uh
preparation the final report
um and we uh is distributed by the
administrative staff and we have final
report template as well as a letter of
transmittal we have samples of that in
the binder that you will be receiving
later
um our staff has been Staffing these
since the 70s and we've worked very
closely with representative Ebel for the
last three three studies right last
three and so where we know what the
numbers are obviously and um
as Deborah's mentioned we get questions
that every other office gets as well and
members keep going from office to office
seeking advice because sometimes they
had nothing to do with the study to
begin with the one member proposed it
and a member accepts it and then they're
scrambling to try and find out how do I
make this happen so I can go into more
detail in our second round
thank you
thank you all right so now we're going
to move on to challenges and Improvement
opportunities
Paul and I are going to cover this
together because many of our issues tend
to overlap
um I guess the the first thing I really
want to point out with these in addition
to everything you've heard so far is
these
um these statutory study commissions
they're creatures of Statute and so in
there's a general lack of guidance and
accountability in the absence of any
specific statutory provision
um and you can contrast that with say a
chaptered study or a um or even a house
standing committee we have house rules
we have the speaker as the presiding
officer who has sort of General
administrative authority over the over
the body
um these you know if if the statute
doesn't specify something like say an
appointment term or how to replace a
member or remove a member there's really
no guidance compared to say our our
house committees and so that presents
problems it gives rise to many of the
questions that Deborah gets that Paul
gets that we all get um and trying to
sort of sort out how to handle a
situation that arises
um and so so having said that the clear
the clearest guy guidance for these
groups is the the requirements of the
right to NOLA RSA 91a that's sort of the
Bedrock of what they do have to follow
these are clearly public bodies because
they've been established by Statute and
so they have to meet uh the both
requirements of the law they have to
abide by open meetings requirements
which means that they have to notice
their meetings and they have to hold
them open from the public and then they
also have to maintain public records
that is they have to keep minutes they
have to keep a file available for
inspection in case somebody wants to
view the materials and then they also
usually file a report
um
the problem is particularly with these
commissions that
um with the the chair is an outside
member and where there's not a clear
connection with the legislature they
don't necessarily know that they have to
follow these rules
um and so the questions that arise tend
to come back through the legislator
who's maybe serving on one of these and
says oh well we heard we have to take
minutes now and which wouldn't be an
issue for say a house committee we know
we have to take minutes because it's in
our rules
um and so I I think that gives rise to
um to many of the questions that we tend
to get and I know Paul's got some
specific examples on those
so just to to Jim's point about a couple
of things so it is important that we do
we we yes this is a special committee on
commissions but we do need to talk about
the committees as well because they
really this whole statute is about
committees and commissions and and so
this really does speak across purposes
so in several instances over the past
couple years there have actually been uh
at least three bills where
um part of the charge was to review the
rules of the House of Representatives to
identify what changes are required to
authorize certain things
um and it's important to note here in
just in in terms of the the lack of
guidance and accountability why would
you appoint a senator
to a house study about house rules
that's just there it reeks of
impropriety um I mean the Senate has a a
fundamental lack of rules where ours are
very specific about certain things and
they don't have a guiding
um a guiding secondary source like we
have Masons they don't have that so
again I I there are certain things here
that that we do have to consider
additionally
want to go back a little bit during the
committee of conference process I have
to review all of the reports to see if
committees or commissions are appointed
in those reports that exceed the
reporting deadlines established by our
own house rules and statute because in
those instances that requires a
two-thirds approval of the committee of
conference report because it is
tantamount to a rule suspension
um
regarding a you know a question
regarding the change to 14 and 49
because this is a new change for this
year is requiring the chairs to get the
reports so the answer in some of those
instances is pretty easy to determine
because of where the bill may have come
from however
this is an issue I I cite an example
because I've been here a long time but
we've had over the years construction
and demolition debris and how it's and
how it's disposed of now in our our body
we have earth air and water
resources gets water environment gets
Earth and science gets air construction
and demolition debris has historically
gone to two committees environment and
science so in those instances who's
getting the reports are we giving them
both so those are some specifics that
that are are sort of coming up
um back to the legal issue again if less
than a quorum has not been appointed
it's not legal to have that meeting and
when we come to notice
where do we where do we need notice
specifically those commissions that are
created legislatively but have no
legislative members because we have
several of those
um we don't take charge of them so in
terms of posting are we responsible at
all for keeping track of those things I
argue no
um and do we have to make sure that the
that the agencies are posting those
things on their own websites or keeping
track of minutes and those sorts of
things so to those first two points you
know regarding the right to know and the
lack of guidance those are those are
things where we are speaking across the
same purpose here
and I think the the other issue that I'd
add and a term at committee governance
issues and I sort of hinted at this
these are largely the issues that
the questions Deborah gets in terms of
appointment terms or reappointment or a
committee needs to reorganize and uh
elect a new chair
um
again if the statute doesn't specify how
that is done it's really an open
question there's not a lot of guiding
law on this Beyond sort of general
principles of Law and so versus say our
standing committees or a chapter study
or a strictly statutory regulatory
committee and so that's why in terms of
Senate Bill 84
you know I think we could debate
the issue of potential administrative
attachment that would certainly clarify
it because it would take it out of our
purview
um but at the same time it doesn't
necessarily resolve the underlying
issues of governance if it's not
clarified in statute so I guess in in
terms of these commissions that from a
legal perspective that's my biggest
concern with these is that the lack of
the lack of legal guidance
um absent statutory author specification
uh additionally in in following up with
Jim here the
if a commission is created one
suggestion regarding tying SBA 84's
language and cleaning this up because I
will tell you from my own perspective I
think that SB 84 doesn't quite get where
everything needs to be and I think that
it would my opinion is that it's best to
probably retain that this year in
legislative Administration so that it
can be worked on for the fall but one of
those suggestions could be regarding the
contents of the commission's work that
Jim's talking about and what the said
repository for that work should be and
and where it should be and and that sort
of thing that can all be clarified
um
for those committees and commissions
that are existing past the term the
concerns about reorganization that Jim
brought up are very very much true
because what happens a lot of times is
uh say we've had a a commission that has
has been on the book since 1977 and has
met and it has been in absence during
covid and they're coming back together
however in 19 or 2017 they did elect a
new chair and that chair appointed a
clerk and they just haven't met because
of covet or whatever the situation is
that if you get a new member of of the
house who has been appointed and that
member then says I'm calling this
commission meeting and we're going to
the first organizational meeting is to
elect a new chair but you have a chair
so these are questions legal questions
that are existing and I and I do think
we do need to talk about that
um I I do
I do think
that
I think the Senate lacks an
understanding of the committee this the
committee process in the adoption of
their amendment to SB 84.
the the change that they made of turning
a study committee a chaptered study
committee into a 15-person committee
makes absolutely no sense especially
because the Senate always amends our
study committee bills to putting one of
them on and we often struggle to get
four or five house members
who want to be on a study so upping that
to 15 I think is is I think they were
trying to make the the switch from
commission but I that they clearly got
it wrong there
um
the point of legislative committee
commissions being capped last session
that we've talked about was because of
the influence of those outside the
general court driving policy versus the
members driving policy and and the
fundamental belief of of the house and
the Senate last term was that
legislators should be the ones focusing
on
adopting legislation and driving the
policy
um and and I think that that's a very
real issue the one area of of SB 84 that
I think is right specifically is the
administrative attachment to the agency
however I do think that the individual
bills
should be drafted with which agency they
should be attached to so that the first
named member who is trying to call the
meeting is not calling around calling
around to an agency that can host versus
an agency that shall host
um and additionally I I do think there
is one additional point that we have to
talk about and that is
what's going to happen if we are now
appointing all these things and these
agencies say well this is going to cost
you some dough
because I will tell you uh we a few
years ago broke the mold with
commissions
we spent five hundred thousand dollars
on a commission now I I'm not going to
get into the details it's not it's not
my point but but the point is is that we
appropriated five hundred thousand
dollars to run a commission that was not
housed here
and that might become the norm if if we
sort of go back to the old model of
commissions and potentially consider
this so I I just mentioned that as a
point that it should be thought about
for what could happen
going into uh the system maintenance I I
do want to address this because this is
where I get a lot of calls
administratively the system when you go
on to our website and look up a
commissioner or committee
um it's sometimes static
because commissions especially with
commissions that meet infrequently or
have never been Sunset that maybe should
have been
uh specifically when Commissioners are
named for certain agencies as being
members uh
we might never hear back after the first
two years of a commission and
Commissioners either have four or five
year terms and
if if we don't get a notification that
there's been a change I there's not
enough time to have somebody live in the
statutory commission's page
and on on our staff either in committee
services or my staff that literally just
spends all their time looking and seeing
who's been updated in terms of of which
agency so that that is something
additionally
um
appointing authorities often send folks
along
because their appointment isn't there
that day
that person doesn't get to vote that
person is not a member of the commission
or the committee
so it's it's important to know that that
the named person is the person
and we don't just have alternates
sometimes people like to throw
alternates at us but the fact of the
matter is if the statute says there are
alternates then there can be alternates
if it doesn't
that doesn't fly and that and that
alternate doesn't just get to vote so
that is uh you can't just sub a player
for the day
um
so lastly to to sort of conclude
um the passage of 1269 last session
helped a great deal in terms of
commissions and committees thank you to
representative evil and the staff that
was working so hard on that some further
modifications that we've already talked
about might make it stronger
um I think SB 84 and its current
iteration needs more work
uh additionally staff has already begun
to identify a few issues to help better
identify committees in Commissions in
their infancy
um culturally though and this is this is
this is where I'm gonna sort of throw
some salt culturally I'm not sure we can
change the perspective of some that
studying issues is already within the
purview of our standing committees
I want to say that again all of you are
on standing committees and every one of
your standing committees can study the
issues because every standing committee
has a description in house rules about
what that that committee can discuss and
it doesn't mean that you just have to
hear bills on those things you can have
ad hoc meetings you can have specific
subject matter discussions and even
bring about legislation so I I do think
it's important
that you remember that and that you
encourage members to talk with their
chairs about these issues
we we we just had a new special
Committee created today
to address uh issues going on in the
family court so there's a special
committee that's been formed just for
that purpose so I mean we have three
other special committees this year one
of which is yours that are are specific
to to serious issues so those those are
important Avenues as well
um
so I I don't know if we can change that
culture but it would be good
um
I I would also just mention too that
that you know just because turning
something into a study committee or a
commission
um might boost your your pass fail
statistics and and getting uh uh which
legislation was signed into law and that
kind of thing I don't know if that
really is is the best use of of of our
resources
um
I know I and the rest of the staff are
here to assist you in this endeavor the
best we can but I also know that there
are sometimes political considerations
as well that we are really we stay away
from uh a specific issue was uh earlier
last month there was a bill that was
being debated on the house floor to
create a study Commission
that was going to study the exact same
thing that's already being studied by
another commission
and unfortunately it did sort of turn
into a political issue even though it
was about a commission that's already
studying a topic
um so again there is this this cultural
thing that we have to we have to think
about when we're invested
thank you Paul
I touched on most of the challenges that
we have at OLS on my first part of my
presentation and just to recap the uh
the commission's uh do follow a certain
process to through OLS we have to mainly
confidentiality with our members
deadlines are a concern for us sometimes
we don't have enough information
for a bill and uh it comes down to the
last minute and then the remember will
request a uh commission to be
established
and again in the end we do what the
member asks us to do
now that being said uh internally we
have made some changes at OLS already
largely to allow the clerk's offices
both the House and Senate to get
information earlier
we are working with it to be able to get
reports and information
shared easier amongst the different
Offices here in the legislature
and we'll continue to do that
the other thing that we are looking at
in OLS is to have more of a
Communications effort as we
start looking at filing period for next
year
uh because that's on our planning table
right now of how we
taking some of the things from this year
and learning from them and moving
forward and one of that one part of that
will certainly be a discussion about
about commissions and the research
opportunities that we that you have with
the OLS OLS has a four-member research
staff that can conduct research for any
individual member as house members you
know house committee services and
research provides research at a
committee level but at OLS we provide
that research for any member of the
House and Senate
and many times
we know that
the information that is in the end
gleaned by a commission
could have been obtained just by coming
to OLS research and getting the
information beforehand and that would
that request had not been made so maybe
a better marketing effort uh for our
staff is well it maybe it is uh it is a
better marketing effort that we will be
uh that we will be doing here as we move
forward and lastly notwithstanding we
can make changes to 1449 to make it seem
lock solid but all we have to do is have
the members say insert notwithstanding
1449 and then that commission can be
anything the member requested to be with
any number of appointees members rules
or not uh that's uh that's something to
keep in mind and that's uh that's an
easy way to uh to avoid some of the some
of the issues some of the uh safeguards
that we are hoping will put in place
thank you
all right so moving on to the appointing
authority and I said previously that I
work for the speaker of the house but I
also consulted with the Senate and they
follow a similar process and have
similar challenges so I'm also speaking
for the Senate when I when I speak today
but keep in mind there are a lot of
appointing authorities there may be
non-profits the governor and various
State departments as well so they all
have their own process as well there's a
lot of people impacted by this
the biggest challenge for me is that
there is no one consistent list of
commissions
we all have our own spreadsheet or
however others track it one of those
reasons is I track all of the speaker's
appointments so it's not just statutory
commissions but it's standing committees
any type of committee committees from
executive order from the governor even
for organizations like CSG and ncsl he
has those appointments as well so I
track those in my in my spreadsheet and
then I also track information that
others may not care about the clerk
wouldn't care about or OLS or even house
committee services so that's why I have
my own spreadsheet right now now the
stars on the on the slides as we've been
going through are areas where we have
made some improvements and we're looking
to make more improvements so this is one
big area where we're looking to share
the data because that's one thing that's
extremely time consuming
next bullet and I I apologize for the
text Heavy slides here but I wanted to
make sure that all these issues were
documented so if you forget what I say
at the end you'll at least have them
bulleted for you
um
so next bullet is commissions may be
duplicative and I think all of us have
spoke to this a little bit they're
overlapping in subject matter and in
membership we have a a you know I want
to say a small number we have 400 house
members but there are very few that
actually serve on the commission so we
have some Representatives that serve on
multiple commissions obviously
and then when when it comes to the
Senate they only have 24 members to
choose from so it's a it's a struggle
from that end too
next bullet policy committee chairs may
lose Authority and insight on subject
matter and Clark Smith's talked about
this so this is opposed as opposed to a
subcommittee or ad hoc committee this
new commission is being created chairs
of standing committees may not even have
any insight at all I mean hopefully
there's some communication but just the
sheer volume of commissions that we have
it's it's unlikely that chairs are
getting all that information back to
them so I feel like they're losing
certainly Authority and and insight and
awareness on some of the things that are
being discussed during these commission
meetings
the large majority of appointments are
needed at the same time at the new
biennium and I mentioned before that I
have my spreadsheet and I track it by
term end date but more than 90 percent
of those all are appointed at the
beginning of a new term so first of all
as you all know at the beginning of a
new term we have to have a speaker
election we can't start making
appointments until we have a speaker
speaker needs to make the appointments
also largely the commissions require
members who serve on a certain policy
standing committee so you know a member
of Judiciary a member of children and
family so obviously after a new term we
have to have all of those appointments
made to the policy committees first
as everybody in this room knows it's
also a very busy time we have a lot of
other things that we're doing in
December after the speaker is elected
after you're put on your policy
committees we're doing seating we're
doing parking there's a lot of work
that's going on so staff and legislators
and of course the speaker has competing
priorities so we're trying to meet the
dates of making these appointments but
it's not always easy
another struggle with them being needed
at the same time as others are involved
in the appointment process so some that
say you know it requires a speaker
appointment it also requires an
appointment from the minority office so
sometimes we have to wait to hear from
another office regardless of who's in
the majority or minority and then if
there are a few commissions that require
joint appointments so it may be the the
speaker the Senate President and the
minority leader from each of the Senate
and the house as well
it can be very time consuming to find
the right appointee
so a pointy requirements may be too
specific I've already mentioned most of
the commissions require you be on a
particular policy committee but there
are other specifics as well one example
was a breastfeeding mother now at the
time the legislator wrote that
particular legislation to create that
commission they may have had somebody in
mind and a reason for putting for
example a breastfeeding mother as a
required appointment by the speaker But
as time goes on it may be less you know
so it's a little bit of an awkward an
awkward appointment for a speaker of the
house or a Senate President to make
perhaps you can consider instead of
being so specific on the appointments
instead reach out to non-profits or have
you know breastfeeding mothers give
testimony in front of the commission
there's a high member turnover each
biennium
and it's challenging with 400 members
for the speaker or even the minority and
majority leaders to be able to get to
know your members when we're replacing a
hundred each term they all have
different skills different talents
different interests and different
availability
many members are unable to serve even
sponsors I have had people who sponsored
legislation so a new commission is going
to be created and they say I do not want
to be appointed to this do not appoint
me to this Commission
members change their mind about serving
or can't serve uh you know maybe their
circumstances change health reasons job
or whatever so we've made appointments
and then they come back and say I'm
sorry I can't serve and that's why some
of you who receive my appointment
notices get multiple and I apologize but
it starts the process over when somebody
can't serve
few members serving impacts us greatly
and by few members I mentioned we have
400 house members for example but it's a
small percentage of those who actually
serve on the commissions so when we lose
them it's a great loss in in many ways
representative Barbara Shaw served on 11
commissions representative Dave
Danielson also served on approximately
11 commissions so when they passed away
last term not only are we dealing with
the loss of of a loved one a fellow
colleague of yours we also have to fill
their
fill their place on their commissions
and then of course resignation somebody
leaves the house same situation so it
impacts us in many ways when you have a
small number of legislators who are
serving on multiple commissions
the large number of commissions take
significant member and staff time
it just you know just the the the the
sheer volume of them and what we have to
do for tracking and managing them and
the number of questions we get on them
inconsistent adherence to RSA for
appointments so we may have too many or
too few appointees when I took over this
job about two years ago
um I would find commissions where the
speaker was supposed to make two
appointees and there were four four
appointees made including creating
alternates when alternates weren't part
of the RSA so it's it's tough because
there's some lack of accountability
there in in tracking these things I gave
here on the slide deck as an example
eliak the legislative youth advisory
Council this is one for a few terms
people were making appointments just to
try to get the numbers up on this so
there were people who were serving
longer than they were supposed to be
serving we had more members than we were
supposed to have and so the cleanup
process I'd be embarrassed to share how
much time it took to get that
straightened out
and then it's just One Challenge is I
mentioned before the the speaker makes
appointments but lots of times it will
say in consultation with a minority or
the minority leader has an appointment
so when I started two years ago I
noticed there were a lot of
um
this is not partisan at all but
Republicans weren't appointed now was
the process for the Republicans who were
in The Minority at the time to look
through the commissions to make their
appointments or is it the role of the
speaker's office I reach out to the
minority when their appointments to be
made that's a part of the process I I
put in place but it can be very
inconsistent and um and having a
standard process will will help us
you'll see there's a star next to that
one because that one was one that was
important to me
Quorum requirements a few of the
staffers here have talked about this so
from a Thor appointing authority
perspective
I have many people coming to me Members
other staffers the Senate and I go to
the Senate sometimes saying look the
chair wants to get this meeting going
but they don't have enough appointees so
sometimes I work with the speaker he may
have three appointments to make but we
only have one member we like to wait
until we have all the members so I can
send out one appointment notice but they
need a quorum to be able to meet so if
we have one member I'll send out an
appointment notice for that one member
and then until we get the others so that
obviously is is time consuming in the
tracking in the appointment notices
getting out but it's important for those
commissions that need their members
appointed as soon as possible
next bullet updating data in the
legislative management system tool is
manual the data isn't current and it
results in many questions so legislative
management tool this is basically our
website if you go to the website and
search on the RSA search on the
different commissions people will come
to me and say hey there's a rep here
listed they're they're appointed but
this member hasn't been a rep in two
years so the process right now is the
clerk's offices will make updates when
they hear of an update but if they're
not getting appointments made then the
then the website will be outdated and of
course this is a challenge at the end of
a term when it's outdated once the new
legislature is sworn in even if you're
serving on a commission because it's
coterminous with your term in office you
have to wait for the next appointment
notice to come out so it's very
challenging to get to keep that that
website updated another reason why many
of us keep our own spreadsheets
accountability is lacking I've touched
on this in a couple other bullets but
some commissions don't meet there's no
indication if action is required from
the reports you know I mentioned that at
the generally at the end of a year
interim and final reports are sent to
the Senate President to the speaker of
the house to the governor and others
it's it's not clear if action is
required the speaker will review some
that he can but a lot of these reports
are extremely thick and he can't read
through all of these especially when
they're coming from hundreds of
commissions
and then there's no well previously no
government governance to repeal
commission so we have uh commissions
sitting around for for some time with no
sunset
this is my last slide
build text for new commissions is
inconsistent
so some and again this has been uh some
areas of this have been fixed going
forward so it won't be as much of a
problem but no Sunset date
um some mention that there's mileage
reimbursement for legislators others do
not some mention a first named or a
chair some don't mention election of a
chair at all
there are lengthy commission names which
is extremely challenging I'm sure some
of you when you enter the office and see
the the screen where it shows the
meetings of the day there will be one
commission that has a name that takes up
the full screen that's how long the
commission names are
and then unclear terms and by this I
mean you know we've we've spoke to this
but
um your term on the commission may be
coterminous with your term in office but
others aren't as clear some will say
that as long as you're still a
legislator you can serve until another
person is appointed
and then some are a little bit confusing
and don't have any guidelines around how
long the term is at all and that's when
I consult my my friend Jim Cianci over
here
identifying new commissions is not easy
or consistent as I mentioned when I was
talking about the process I'm sometimes
notified by the clerks I'm notified by
another member I'm notified by a state
department who says I need this
appointment made I'm notified by the
news and by searching rsas so when the
staff when we stop started meeting I
came to learn that all of us searched
through the rsas to find out if
commissions or boards or committees are
created and it's literally searching on
those that text looking if there's a
board advisory Council and that's
extremely time consuming and it may
sound silly but that was the way that we
were finding all of the commissions and
if you take into consideration hb2 last
year there the it was in the double
digits the number of commissions that
were created in hb2 alone now my friends
in both Clerk's offices are going to
notify me so I won't be searching rsas
anymore
foreign
next bullet legislation has meeting or
report deadlines that may be
unattainable very difficult to meet so a
new bill comes in by the time it's
signed by the governor and then gets on
my desk it already may be
too late we haven't even made
appointments to the commission yet and
they were supposed to meet last month
lots of times the meetings or final
reports are in you know November or
December but there have been a couple
that were like October 15th and I'm
making the appointment on November 1.
and then after a new term new
commissions have just started so they
lose momentum so we we create a new
commission the appointment gets out they
start meeting in November and now
there's an election and some of the
legislators may be here for the next
term some may not but either way it
makes it challenging and confusing
confusing when I send out a new
appointment notice and somebody's like
we just had our election for a chair
and now I will turn it over to my friend
Anne
thanks Debra
so when we come everything that has been
shared by the entire staff panel house
Community Services agrees with every
single thing and practically everything
was brought up I was going to emphasize
as well and how it impacts our staff
because we are the ones who end up
sitting in these conditions or
committees throughout their term whether
it's July to December or a couple years
for the most part we are the ones who
sit there with them and we deal with the
outside membership
that doesn't understand the legislative
culture or how the legislative staff
functions
my first bullet I put up we have the
numerous new committees and commissions
so while we're just working with the
previous ones also and we get a new
slate of them and we have to start all
over again with these new ones and add
them on top of the old ones
sometimes we have commissions as Paul
mentioned they're already in existence
they're already working on issues and
the members brought in a new bill and
the commission was passed and studying
the exact same thing so we staff have to
sit and explain to the new membership
yes you're brand new but this already
exists and you might want to contact the
previous commission or the existing
commission see how much work they've
done we had this process several years
ago when we had six six commissions at
the same time on dcyf and the head of
dcif had to attend one time all six
commissions were meeting the exact same
week and he spent all this time here at
meetings telling each group what he was
doing
so it's very frustrating for staff to
see that happening
and we so when you add the new
commission commissions we do go through
legislation as everyone mentioned we all
have to search everywhere to find these
items we did in 2010 or start I think in
09 what that was our first major search
and we had all staff involved we had
legislation I was precursor to
representative evil studies it was
representative Lori Harding was in
charge and all of OLS our entire office
the Senate staff we searched everything
it came up with the master list of all
the existing commissions and and we
thought this was the end-all to be all
and then 10 years later we were back at
the same things because they grow and as
we've mentioned we come up with plans
and ideas in fact
um it's not in binder although I do love
binders but this expandable file holds
all of the staff recommendations so
we've had over the years on how to help
curb these and we do okay for a year or
two and then we're back to the same
situation because members figure out how
to bring in new legislation so for
instance a new bill a Senate Bill I just
spotted on Friday actually as we
mentioned
um when we amended 14 you amended 1449
last year we came up with the 15 member
commission and we also and Paul it has
it's limited outside correct is that
okay so what what the legislation says
now is
within the um where would you used to
say I would say a member of the Bia will
now say
um it directs the Bia and say New
Hampshire auto dealers another group
they're to get together and come up with
one person to represent them so that's
the way but that how will the clerk's
office write to all those entities and
explain to them this is what you have to
do so that's a new workaround so every
time we go over here there's another way
they figure um
around it so that's how we get to all
these numerous new communities and
commissions
um and then my next bullet point
commissions have large memberships one
of the biggest challenges we ever had
was when a 45-member commission was
created we couldn't we tried to square
the rooms around there was no way we
could house a 45-member commission here
so luckily we found a place at Seacoast
and that's where they met and we had
um a member who was very active with
house community services so we were able
to be it was all outside people Regional
planning groups I think we had one or
two members on it so we worked with all
the regional planning groups and they
actually came and met with us and we
instructed them on the legislative
process and what to do but you can
imagine that's taking our time away from
working with other um committees
um and Deborah emphasized my next bullet
is that um
it takes a long time to make all the
appointments so um and not all entities
want to be on a commission in one
instance we had a member who kept
bugging us uh or Not by getting this you
know asking us please please please they
wanted us to call all the organizations
to find out why they hadn't appointed
anyone well that takes a great deal of
time but in one instance we did make
some calls the organization said we we
don't want to be active in this study we
want nothing to do with this study and
we told the member and the member said
well they they have to and then and the
organization said we're not appointing
anybody so we couldn't make a quorum
um and then again sometimes by the time
the Quorum has been met and this has
happened not only has it passed the
effective date but sometimes we have not
made a quorum until the reporting week
until November 1 or in in one case over
the last two years the committee sat
vacant for 18 months it could not meet a
quorum because it could not find anybody
who was willing to sit on the commission
um
the non-legislator chairs and
non-legislative members it can often be
difficult because as I mentioned earlier
they don't understand the culture of the
legislative process they have they other
than right to know they have no rules to
follow they don't have the speaker they
the chief of staff is not here and we
could have some very unique individuals
who have expectations of staff that we
are there to solely serve that one
commission and we need to explain that
we we um not only do we have our
standing committee work but we have to
be available for other commissions and
other chapter studies and especially as
you all know you have again a 21 member
commission well in the old days but who
knows what will change and then you have
only one or two legislators on it and
the other 19 people you're working for
even the chairman
um is now a member of the legislature
and sometimes it's a senator the house
staff is working for
um
so this can
um and then the continuity that that
Deborah mentioned that can also also
happen
um particularly on the long-term study
timeline issues my last bullet
um so what happens is and here's she was
wonderful uh representative Mary Stuart
guile had a fantastic commission 10
years she worked on this thing she had
all of her everything was done
unfortunately before she retired there
was no repeal date on her legislation so
the new Administration appointed someone
to that and that member wanted to get
going again but all the committee the
entire commission membership said no
we're done our work here is completed
but the new member did not agree with
that and so that new member kept going
from office to office trying to get
um going and and finally we scheduled
the meeting and everybody who attended
the meeting said our work is done but
all the prep work that staff had to take
to set that up
um was unfortunate
um
and you have as as Paul mentioned that
situation where we had there was a large
appropriation that came in with the
study commission and within that
legislation it specifically said no
legislative staff was to be involved in
this study that's why I was supposed to
be completely out of here well once the
bill was uh passed and uh the
um sponsor they came to legislative
staff the LBA accounting our office I
said what do we do so this says right
here not to do anything well where do we
go what do we do
well that was should that hadn't been
all thought out and how do we do this
so that took a great deal of time
several offices several days and trying
to figure out how to proceed
um we have and I can go on obviously I
have a lot of anecdote
um stories I can tell you over the years
I've I've dealt with all this and as I
mentioned we had the 2010 study and then
all the three studies that
representative evil worked so hard on
and yet here we are explaining
everything to you and that's why I
thought this was such a wonderful
opportunity for staff because you have
to see we can see all the numbers
hanging there but we all need to see
what is the problem in the background
and how do you members solve it because
what members
the cultures changed when I came in 84
we had just gotten done with the
Constitutional Convention and we had
just passed um annual sessions and one
of the things that was stated and I kept
hearing from everywhere we're no longer
going to have commissions the standing
committees will now study all these
issues
and here we are
so um so that's something to consider
that was a goal back then and
um then you can
a chair one of my chairs had a two-year
study on special education and it was
fantastic but it was ad hoc the
committee worked so hard and they came
out with nine pieces of legislation but
the issue stayed in the committee and
they discussed it and they worked within
their committee it was not assigned to a
statutory that that took it outside of
the realm of the legislators the ones
who are elected to do this
um and as Deborah also mentioned
we do run into a lot of members who are
named to a commission
um or or it's a it's a brand new
commission and they're first named and
they're organizing and yet another
member wanted it to be studied but
wanted nothing to do with the issue and
as as Dave mentioned
we've often said in anecdotally we've
heard um because Myla you know head of
OLS researcher research we're best
friends so we work together all the time
and it's unfortunate that
someone goes into drafting they have an
idea they don't have time to do the
research so they say well let's create a
commission it's unfortunate they didn't
go in a month or two ahead of time go
into see Myla and say could could your
office please look this up for us or
also even with our own committees um the
standing committees if we created
subcommes while they're I know we we
went very fast this session but
sometimes that's one of the great things
about retained bills you have more time
to study but it's being held within your
committee and it's the legislators who
are in charge not some outside group and
we do know again anecdotally that
they're outside groups lobbying groups
advocacy groups who promote commissions
with their own membership because say
you have an opportunity to work on
policy and that's not a bad idea because
if you have a chaptered study these
people can come and talk before you they
don't have to be an appointment to the
group that's another thing members don't
always understand that you can have say
a five-member chaptered study and invite
the 10
stakeholders and have them come in and
meet with your group and meet come to
every meeting
because what you're trying to do is
share the information as I mentioned
about representative Mary Stuart guile
and also representative Pat abrami they
were real driving forces behind their
study commissions and with when
representative Gile had retired and
obviously representative brahmi left
this past session and their commissions
that drive is gone and what happens is
who picks up the slack
um to push those studies
so
that's been my experience in the
experience of our office but it's also
is shared in that as you've heard from
every one of us here it's the amount
it's not the issue of the study a study
is a study you it's the vehicle that
you're using and so that vehicle takes
so much time and energy wouldn't it be
better to have that time and energy
devoted to analyzing whatever the issue
may be as opposed to trying to organize
um so I hope that um from our
perspective or my perspective I was able
to share some of that
with all of you
um and that's it for me thank you
oh gosh yes oh my gosh so I
representative and I said come here I've
seen that so so anyway those are all the
studies since 1981 they're upstairs on
the fourth floor lots and lots and lots
of boxes and then and that doesn't even
include all the electronic um
studies but that's where they go
and that's where where you can find them
thank you
all right thank you so much for your
patience and listening to us it's
clearly very uh we're all passionate
about the subject matter
and we know it's a lot of information
but want to open it up to questions
thank you doctor
um
I have a couple of questions I'll kick
it off and then I'll turn it over to the
committee that asks what questions you
have
a couple of things
would it be appropriate
uh kind of picking up where Ann left off
as as we look at
the breadth of committee chairmanships
across
the legislature that you know you look
you know you're a committee chair you're
in charge of the Agricultural uh
committee whatever would it be
appropriate to say that oh and by the
way you have oversight of these 15
commissions and you in finance you have
oversight of these 27 commissions so
that all the commissions could be split
up by committee chair to uh
to provide oversight to provide
leadership commentary and so forth is
that is is that an option available to
us or is that a rules issue
well the the way
we've been doing it now for the past
couple years and this year too is that
Deborah usually contacts the committee
chair for recommendations
and in context you know the Democratic
office for recommendations depending on
how the commission is done
so in essence
they are kind of
split up not reality but in essence they
are pretty much split up because
we are just having and we've had had
uh and I'm sure speaker Charlotte have
had the same problem people want these
things but they don't want to serve on
them
and that's why we have members you know
serving on multiple loved ones because
they're the only ones that are willing
to do it
and that's why these things have become
such a problem is that if we could split
it up between all 400 members
that would take the load off the members
that are serving but it doesn't
alleviate the problem of where they're
going to meet in all the other things
that go along with it
but it's it's it's getting out of hand
and I I have full confidence that you
know as a as a committee you guys can
fix it
I will tell you one thing uh that I have
made a decision that if the first name
the sponsor of a committee or a a
commission especially is going to be put
on that Commission
yeah Mr chairman just to just to address
your your direct question though the the
fact of the matter is you ask about
having oversight of those commissions
that the situation is you can't
the the the commissions are are really
autonomous yes they rely on us somewhat
but at the end of the day their
recommendation
the report that they draft that that
might say we should sponsor a bill that
does these 15 things it's up to then up
to the legislative member to file that
legislation
so again it's
yes it sounds great that we say to
representative Weiler hey these these 15
commissions are under the purview of
Finance but if representative Weiler
decides to go to those 15 commission
meetings and give them what for they can
tell them exactly what for back
and if I may share one way that chairs
have been able to help in the past uh
representative rice and Senator Carson
working with staff looked at a lot of
their
children and family related commissions
and were able to consolidate some last
term so they took two or three and moved
them into another commission the
children oversight commission so that
was one way that they Consolidated it
saying hey these are it's like subject
matter and we can move that into one
commission okay a question for the for
the legal guys
and then I'll turn it over the rest of
the committee for questions I know a
different
there are different uh Lo probably lower
forms of government at the local level
that deal with this problem of
people not showing up or no Quorum uh
and so forth uh in the way that they
typically do it would be
if you don't if you don't show up for a
meeting three times in a row you're off
you're gone and uh and it's up to the
committee chair to reappoint somebody
else or whoever the pointing Authority
is the other the other part of that
would be if the if the committee we've
heard about committee or commissions
that don't achieve a quorum over and
over again
uh that if the quorum's not achieved X
number of times in a row the com the
committee is automatically or the
commission is disbanded uh
so is are those would those be options
that we could pursue uh as you know in
in our role in this special committee
you could um you'd have you'd have to
specify it in the statute and I think
this gets back to the issue of so to
borrow your example say you had a um
excuse me a standing committee or a
chaptered committee and you had a member
of the House who consistently just
didn't show up the speaker within his
authority can replace that member I mean
that's that's clear under our house
rules it's under our practice and
precedent and it's an easy process to do
same thing with lack of corn because
it's within our Authority within our
body
when it's a statutory commission and
Paul hinted on this this in response to
your previous question
um
certainly I think there's some leeway to
do that but if it's not specified in the
statute that process for replacing
members or a lack of Quorum or
disbanding for lack of Quorum it's an
open question
and so that's why I sort of the theme of
my presentation was in the absence of
statutory Authority there's not as much
guidance or oversight versus a standing
committee or a chaptered committee or
even an ad hoc there's much more
authority to do the types of things that
you're suggesting would that be some
standard language you could advise us on
that when somebody comes when a
legislature comes to you and says they
want to create a commission
that you could advise them that one of
the things that the speaker would like
to have is this standard language and in
that standard language would be
you know the uh three
uh meetings and you're out or three lack
of quorums and the committee is a
commission is dismanded I mean is that
something that that we could put in
place that that the legislature may not
be aware of that you are a template to
them and here's here's how to create a
commission language
yeah I mean I think you could draft
something I'd want to think about how to
do that particularly in terms of if it's
a legislative member versus a
non-legislative member because again
you're when you're creating a statutory
Commission in in many ways you're
seeding a certain level of legislative
Authority
um and so you'd have to be very specific
about you know the consequences of any
person missing three meetings and then
who can replace it and potentially if
there's a challenge to that say the
person couldn't attend three meetings
because they were sick
um you know you'd have to be pretty
clear I think on how you'd want to do it
I'm not suggesting you couldn't
but there are different considerations
and commissions versus the other types
of studies thank you I have some more
questions but I'll turn it over to my
colleagues
okay I can't please
well I have to say I have a little bit
of PTSD just listening to all this
because I think we all talked so much
about all this stuff and it's just
phenomenal uh to see it all written down
and thank you very much for doing it I
just have a couple of comments if that's
all right if as opposed to questions I
guess one thing I just I'm not sure
everyone is aware but when you're
talking about uh the numbers of
commissions I mean my memory is that we
had like 180 to 200 commissions we just
had an unbelievable number and it
required something in the vicinity of
300 appointments so if you think of all
the other work that's going on at the
beginning of a term to do all those
appointments too is just kind of um
mind-blowing
um I just there was just several things
I just want to add to the conversation
so one is uh when Paul was talking about
culture one of the things is that it's
really hard to get legislators to accept
the fact that
um a a a chaptered study committee a
five-person legislator based committee
can do work as well if not better as a
commission that has you know a dozen to
two dozen members that I don't know if
it's a status sort of concept but you
really I mean I've done it both ways you
can have a legislative study commission
and believe me the people that are
interested will show up every time and
you can make like working groups and you
can come up with really effective
recommendations
and the legislators Drive the process I
learned this from Anne the legislators
Drive the process as opposed to
everybody else and it's much easier to
get a quorum in those circumstances than
with many of these commissions
legislators just have to take a little
bit of responsibility the other thing is
they appoint they want these appointees
as you folks described but the
legislators should be asking the people
who they want to be on these commissions
whether they even want to be
a lot of times they just don't I mean I
remember the Bia had been appointed to
like 10 committees and they just
couldn't do it and so you know just
thinking about policy the legislators
have to take uh responsibility the other
thing is a lot of times freshmen
legislators that's one of the they come
and they want to do a commission or a
committee and they end up being the
first main member and they're the ones
that take the most hand-holding because
they have absolutely no experience with
uh with doing it and it just it it makes
things really
um complicated the other thing I just
want to say and I want this is sort of a
question one thing that we learned going
through it is
regardless of whether a Senate bill or a
house bill created a study committee the
house committee Services was really
being expected to Bear The laboring Ore
and hopefully at this point it's been
pretty clear now that if it's a senate
created study committee the Senate Bears
the laboring or and not the house that
that that is is going to be
re-emphasized uh when we have Germans
and a vice Germans meeting that if the
Senate Bill comes over
and wants to have us be in charge of it
that that is going to be an amendment to
that commission before it's passed that
the Senate is the ones that are going to
be in charge if it's the Senate
commission right because it's not it's
not yeah it's not it's not right and and
uh
maybe that'll stop them sending over
commissions I think we got 25 or 30 or
something again this time I know what in
the bills they send over 172 bills and
there's got to be 25 or 30 Commissions
in there
so just one other comment um as much as
we dislike study committees and
commissions
well run they really do provide really
good information so one of the big
um impetuses especially in the the last
committee on committees that we did is
to try to make sure that if you're doing
a commission or a committee the
information the report gets to the
people that should have it and that I
mean in my mind was always committee
chairs that serves two purposes one is
they know that these committees exist so
they shouldn't be duplicating them and
the other thing is they have the benefit
of the report so I understand like when
um Paul just said that sometimes it's
not clear who the right person is to get
that but my fallback would be you just
send it to both but the point is if
we're going to go to all this effort we
just really have to get the information
um to the people that should have it so
they can benefit from it and the only
other thing that we heard on several
occasions was that people who are
preparing these reports there should be
a little more specificity in the statute
on what should be in the reports because
if they're producing reports they should
be useful
so that's that's just sort of my
comments but thank you ever so much for
this
would you believe I read them all
but uh I I I want to make it I guess
make it clear I'm not saying we should
never pass any commissions or committees
or anything else I chair the commission
that set up the Moose plate and I mean
that was a lot of work too but anyways
we had a number of different agencies
and everything involved in that so it's
not to ban them but if we're going to
create them let's make damn sure that
they're doing something in that they
actually meet and they actually
accomplish something or as you said if
there's one that's similar then let's
combine them
so the other problem like with the
committee on committees we really
couldn't take substantive action so if
you want to do the thing where you
combine thing uh three or four
committees that have similar topics it's
really hard to do that if you're not the
policy committee so that's just
something I don't know whether a
committee a committee could make a
recommendation or or whatever but it's
really hard if you're not the policy
committee I think to take a substantive
position on a policy matter
what I think
thank you who who else uh on the
committee would like to speak yes
representative thank you very much Mr
chairman thank you all for coming and
doing this presentation today I've had a
lot of things on my mind and I one of
the things I thought back on is when we
had the right to know commission it was
a very large one and I don't remember
the details of it but I do remember
there was a terrible terrible problem
getting a quorum to do anything and that
Commission because they couldn't get
anything done decided to have
legislation filed so they could continue
the commission on which they did nothing
and I'm sorry I don't mean to be
critical but that's what happened and I
sat on the committee which they reported
to Judiciary and um they came back
finally with a piece of legislation that
made no sense and said we know it makes
no sense but we are required to file
something what do we do with a
commission that's not getting anything
done I don't remember how that
commission dissolved I don't remember
what happened but is there some system
we can have in place if if a quorum
can't be brought together or if a
commission can't accomplish anything is
there something we can do to stop a
commission besides having a sun setting
preposition I think it just laid out one
of your charges
okay thank you
um and also made me stop and think about
some other processes in terms of people
sponsoring I do know if one member
won't speak of who it is was yes uh who
was very proud of serving on 14
different commissions how does one
extend himself or herself to serve on so
many and how does work get done
when there are so many commissions that
again seem to be duplicative or similar
to each other but not quite duplicative
what can we do
well that that again is one of the main
problems is that
so small amount of members actually
serve on so many different committees
and commissions because it's it's the
only ones we can get to do it
uh and I you know I mean as we say we uh
Deborah calls the committee chairman and
finds out you know their recommendations
and then the phone calls have to be made
are you willing to serve and a vast
majority of the time members says oh no
I'm too busy I haven't got time and you
know that kind of thing so it again it
comes down to
a small amount of members serving on
multiple committees
and and I think that detracts from the
uh the ability of the uh you know the
Committees to to meet and actually
present good what you know good uh
solutions to whatever the uh committee
was formed for
Mr chairman can I can I try to address
this this actually gets back to another
point that representative evil mentioned
as well
um I might suggest you as a committee uh
invite the various committee chairs here
uh so that they can share those
duplicative commissions with you uh
certainly representative Ladd who serves
on three dozen of those things can talk
about that with respect to education and
perhaps that can be the basis of
legislation uh that that you all put
forward for next year so so it might be
a good idea to to consider uh bringing
your colleagues in for for those kind of
conversations and are you suggesting a
consolidation piece of legislation type
well I mean it that just that was just
based off of the the comments from
representative wall and representative
evil being a policy decision it if you
bring the policy committees together to
to make those decisions uh for you all
to to put in joint legislation on it
that might be a good idea
question
um
I've been on committees before one in
particular where we discouraged members
from filing bills for commissions and
explained that we were taking people
away from the state agencies and
departments where they needed to do
their work and spending too much time
over here that's why we would have a
study committee so they could come and
be referenced people but not serve on
the commission as members
I agree with the fact that we ought to
have the leadership of the Committees
talking with the members about all this
but I think also be very helpful during
orientation a lot of new members come in
and are going to change the world and I
respect that to some extent
but all of a sudden we see a lot of
commissions and committees set up and I
don't think we are explaining that well
enough to new members they don't
understand the amount of time and
responsibility it takes to serve on
these just a comment thank you
sure yeah I I sounds like a
recommendation to me I I don't want to
impugn anyone's intentions but I think I
have seen
where somebody comes in with with the
with the world on a on a pin and wanting
to change it uh
and they get into their committee and
it's not going well
so rather than let the proposed Bill die
they convince their colleagues to study
it
and study it on a commission or whatever
to say and just to keep it alive and
that that unfortunately happens too
often any anybody else want to jump in
or has a thought yes representative
thank you Mr chairman so I
I've sort of jotted down a number of
bullet points that I think are potential
courses of action and I guess I just
wanted to go through those and hear
uh from anybody who's interested in
chiming in sort of is this
is that am I on the right track is this
kind of uh complete list or is there
anything else here so I think some of
what I heard was obviously we could
repeal repeal or consolidate some of
these that would be introducing new
legislation we could
um promote standardized standardization
of some of the language around these any
future committees or commissions that
get established
um also editing the enabling language in
RSA 1449 to perhaps incorporate some
automatic sunsets you know some some
Provisions that would sort of
automatically Sunset some of these
things
educate standing committees and
committee chairs about the possibility
of studying some of these as a standing
committee rather than creating another
committee and then
um in line with a comment that was just
made I I think
um educating new members but to some
extent perhaps existing members as well
it's always it's people want to be nice
I don't want to kill your bill it's a
study commit yeah I can vote for that
and and and so I I think it's it's a
classic example of where we're looking
at the the the the benefits but we're
not looking at the costs and so
um
I I almost feel like we need a uh a
summary of what has been discussed so
far in the room today that we give to
every uh committee chair and we say you
know before you you know at the
beginning of the exact session on any
bill that creates a standing committee
read through these challenges that that
uh that we experience as a result of
having too many of these so that was
kind of my list of notes as as I've been
listening today and I'm just curious to
hear whether that is there anything else
that we should add to that is there
anything on there that doesn't belong on
there
um just looking for thoughts
thank you anybody else
what we're going to do soon here is talk
about
fall our fallen one meetings for our
committee here and what the schedule
might look like
um and uh taking lunch break here in a
few minutes and uh come back in about an
hour or so uh any further comments from
the uh from the panel yes
thank you representative Dolan one of
the things I want to mention
um in the material that we're going to
hand out to later we do have a list of
when we try to create
consistent language in in the drafting
um of some of these bills so for
instance we used to have committee
reports that could come in on any day
and then we decide November 1
was was the best day because it was
right before the election then and then
but this was
um had been in agreement I think in 1995
by the speaker and the Senate President
and also reports could go anywhere and
at that point in time is when it was
listed the speaker the Senate President
the governor the two clerks and the
State Library so we have had an in and
in the material will hand out to you we
have the um not only the list of the
legislative initiatives but just the
general initiatives by practice or
agreement on on how we could shape some
of these these things so at least you'll
have some historical perspective on how
to move forward and hopefully coming up
with suggestions on how we could
um possibly recommend to the drafters if
we could be consistent in this language
it could help everyone to understand
um I mean I have to add this one piece
though even though we came up with that
November one deadline
then eventually
um years later because you don't have
the same Administration some some in the
Senate changed it to December 1 and then
it did cause a problem of or January 1
and did cause a problem that we had
before but that's only been in a few
since it hasn't been a a big problem but
I just want you to know if that exists
and you'll be able to see that list laid
out
thank you
anybody else
that was great
please please uh take us so sorry
we have a few next steps that we wanted
to touch on before we part
um first of all staff is going to
continue to meet and work on some of the
Improvement opportunities that we've
been focused on one being a data cleanup
and some type of it solution so we can
get rid of our multiple spreadsheets and
and have all of the data available to
legislators and staff so we are working
on that
in sorry in your binder when you receive
your binder at the end there is a draft
list of commissions just so you know we
put that together just for your purposes
so we Consolidated mine and house
committee services in the Senate and
created one for you we do have a lot
more columns in our own spreadsheets but
we tried to include name RSA and then if
the if the commission is meeting
we're also we've been talking about uh
continuing ed opportunities to help
educate legislators on the commissions
and some of our challenges as well
that's something we expect that will
work with work with you on and then a
potential you know cheat sheet or
tri-fold of commission guidelines
um just you know before somebody files
legislation Because by the time they get
to OLS as Dave mentioned where too late
sometimes so if we can get some
guidelines in front of legislators as
soon as possible
and now we can give you your binders
before you part for lunch and just want
you to know that we are here this is
important to all of us so if you need us
please reach out to any of us and thank
you so much
thank you doctor
we have at our disposal uh
room 104 on the first floor which is
right right next to the guard desk and
the the kiosk mileage kiosk on the right
hand side as you come in the back door
so uh what I'm thinking is that you may
not want to drag these uh binders around
with you everywhere you go
uh like I know John Willy he's a he's
crazy for binders but
um
if you want to store them in 104 in the
back room there's room to do that I
would make sure you put your name on it
or one of your business cards and and so
you know whose is whose uh and uh
and we'll be we'll be able to uh
reference that at our meetings uh and
you won't you won't have to uh drag it
with you from home every time you come
to one of these meetings
all right the the uh the last thing I
wanted to uh talk about before we go to
lunch uh just a quick question uh
is it David is uh are you attorney
eloconus no no I am not okay I just want
to get the titles right you mentioned
that 45 bills
were uh came in that created or adjusted
Commissions in the most recent session
can you give us a breakdown where they
come from the senate or the house or I I
can't then that information is about two
weeks old now uh
I'd have to do more research on that
because as you heard from uh Deborah
I literally have to search by the term
commission committee uh to get a list
and then uh so I'd have to do additional
and additional research one last
question before lunch is
we talked about
um
many commissions are being attached
being attached to executive
uh
staff
or follow-up is it does that have a
Governor's implication or to uh Mr
chairman that that's part of the Senate
Bill 84 provision that is now before the
house in legislative Administration and
I would just note that representative
Sheehan and representative wall are both
on legislative Administration and that
bill has been scheduled for a public
hearing and I'm sure that you will
expect a couple of us to be there
testifying okay thank you thank you
all right well with that being said why
don't we uh why don't we break for lunch
and be back here at uh at one o'clock
and we'll uh we'll finish up and just
hide some of the methodology going
forward of how we're going to kind of
slice this up and and try to digest
these big bites of information that we
have in front of us and I'll rely on
representative evil to help us
because she's been through this before
and been tortured once twice already so
uh
with with that thank you all for coming
it's been very helpful and very
educational
we'll see you at one o'clock
get a huge
all right if you guys could uh break out
your calendars and let's do a
a calendar check of when we think it's
the least painful for us to meet going
forward
um
I'm cognizant of the April vacation
which is the the 24th to the 28th was
ready to Black that out
and just in general how do you feel
about
uh which day of the week you want to
meet you like Mondays you like
Fridays uh someone said they didn't like
Friday no Fridays no Friday
Monday's good for you
transportation
time so
okay so so Monday seems like the least
the least uh disruptive Monday mornings
or afternoons or either one
you like morning
I'll be late
I have first Monday of every month I
have an appointment
so other than that I'll be here
and
I was thinking that uh
the way we might attack this
is the way of a regular committee would
attack things like this with
subcommittees
uh maybe what we do is
we get the the list of all the different
commissions
we cut them up into groups and then a
sub a subcommittee could attack these 20
commissions another great track leads to
Lincoln and then we come back together
and and reveal what we've
decided or learned during that
subcommittee activity the other thing is
maybe a subcommittee to attack processed
you know what what what's the right way
what's the language that ought to be in
that goes to OLS as a standard template
when some When A legislature brings
forth an idea to create a commission or
a committee
to OLS OLS should be able to pull out of
their bag of tricks well here's the
here's the template that we want you to
use that we'd like you to use for that
and that would steer
the legislator in a certain direction
with hopefully with the with the help of
their
caucus
the office and as well as the committee
chair say if you're going to do that in
this committee or in this caucus we'd
like you to kind of go in this direction
but without tying their hands but at
least encouraging certain behaviors or
certain activities
so that might be a subcommittee you know
on language and process
and
a couple other subcommunities on
commissions themselves
and I think what I'd like to say and
for for give the use of language but
there are certain sacred cows
that we're going to run into I think in
this in this process
and it's my thought that we have enough
of a huge elephant to attack that I
think we can skip the sacred cows push
them aside and leave them alone and
we'll still have plenty to do
so if so if some of us individually or
collectively based on inputs from our
respective caucuses saying this is a
very important commission that needs to
keep going or needs to be supported or
needs to be encouraged
and we'll just let's just take a
hands-off approach to it and
treat it as a sacred cows and that's
important to the Democratic caucus or
the Republican caucus or whatever so
we're not going to mess with it we've
got 400 opportunities
that will probably
not going to get too deep into that as
it is so my thought is let's attack
those things that we can come to easy
agreement on and not fight about the the
ones that are so-called sacred cows that
that we want to to encourage to continue
first right
yes ma'am
the purpose to Define what
is
and why people prefer Australia
committees if needed local clinicians
because commissions take their agency
the department preparation of employers
out of their jobs and it's lost on their
work
I remember when there was a particular
chairman of
um resources
who what helps the permissions for that
she would have Independence
Wisconsin Department
so
um those people can come in and tell us
tomorrow
as they vote on a position
okay so
um
what we can do is uh
well let's let's first let's just let's
do some easy stuff first let's look
while your calendars are open uh let's
pick our next meeting time you think
this same time next week is good next
Monday you want to do Monday morning
yeah
I'll leave two hours
you want to go 10 to 12.
10 10 to 12 or 9 to 12 or what do you
think
that somebody wanted to experience
you go ten a nine
um well I'll be late anyway
yes ma'am
okay
how about uh
is would ten to one be okay that kind of
jumps into the middle of lunch but
if we just said that we we'd end it
time a non-break for lunch enough to
come back okay all right I'll be here
I'll be here later ten to one sounds
good
all right
ten to one
all right so in that next meeting would
be 17th
Monday the 17th
yeah the next week will be off
and then May 1st
maybe is that a bad day for you
that's okay school vacation week
foreign
well
you you think about May 1st if you can't
make it you can't make it's okay
well we won't count on you very first
sure that's fine
yeah that's the ten to one
unless unless
someone wants to change that 9 to 12 or
10 to 10 to 12 you know a lot of this if
we're going to be off in subcommittee
formats I mean you could do a meeting
on on a Wednesday with two other people
on uh
electronically or half half and half I I
don't think we'll have any restriction
uh
whether whether we do you don't like
electronic meaning
uh no no Zoom subcommittees you think
that's what the rule is
I know he I know he hates the zoom
meetings
well subcommittees can meet
you know because we don't have to
announce a subcommittee right
subcommittees can you can meet at any
time
yeah we can figure out what day we will
whoever the subcommittee chair is you
can decide how you want to meet or where
you want to meet whether you want to
meet
at a local restaurant or a McDonald's or
here or whatever I think the
subcommittees do need to be noticed you
think so no committee still yeah
all right I'll find I'll find out yeah
yeah I think they do but but we can
figure it out
as a subcommittee and figure out we
don't have to meet from the same day as
the committee correct correct but I
those subcommittee meetings
you're right I know I just
I mean I like the idea of meeting at a
restaurant yeah
yeah I'm personally going to be in Spain
the week of May 8th
so that's that's me in India right so
and I'm not going to zoom in from Spain
tormolinos
hey I did tdys to Terre honed but I I do
have advice here and he can uh
cheer for me if that happens if if
that's a conflict
uh so let's let let's just plan on the
next three meetings
uh 417
and 5 8. that uh reasonable and that'll
be from ten to one
in 104. right in in room 104 do you guys
all know what 104 is
behind us right behind the keyboard
and um
it's a it's a much smaller room than
this
uh so that's why we didn't have it there
today because with uh with the panel we
had we wouldn't have had enough room
and in the back of the room
this uh there's places for you to put
your stuff your notebooks or anything
any paraphernalia you want to come and
leave it in there
yeah
well if if
I'll either assure that's unlocked or
the vice chair will and it all uh
in a panic mode the guard that's sitting
at that desk and come around and unlock
it
I've I've asked for a special key for
myself but I don't I haven't got it yet
so but the guard's not too far away to
unlock it
um
and then uh we'll see how that goes and
then we'll
see how we uh want to continue our dates
after that makes sense and Nick and at
the next meeting our agenda uh informal
agenda for our meeting on the
uh on the 17th
let's see here on the 17th yeah will be
uh
to decide how we want to split up into
subcommittees what makes sense so what
you if you have a certain hunger for
process or whatever and you want to work
on the process part of this with with
OLS that would draw you in that
direction or if you decide you know I
just wanna
okay let's get after the commissions
themselves you can do that too so so I
would ask you to come prepared to decide
this is what I want to volunteer for
I think
it needs a sense of specifically what we
need to recovery so we can decide well
part of that I'm hoping that you'll help
with given your experience and Karen
people's experience uh
things like what is help with
definitions what is a commission what is
it study committee what is a full
committee and and and lay that out
so that not only will be on the same
sheet of music but it's maybe something
we could provide with the new freshman
as an education primer
yeah I think that that would be good
well at least think about it so that you
can decide you know if if you want to be
on a process
subcommittee that that would be
something you certainly would would take
on
yes ma'am
perfect
oh yeah I see it
what a concept
this is your homework
well I think with that also it just
brought to mind we ought to all read and
study a little bit RSA 14
9. so we know what what that says
because that's kind of the governing
uh rules for how how we how these things
should behave and and plus we get Senate
bill is it 84 that's coming up
yeah I don't think 84. I don't think we
need to study that so much yeah we're
going to hijack that anyway but one of
the thoughts
uh
about how we go for that and John why
don't you mention what your thought was
on that what are you for yeah all right
um when I was thinking and I kind of
mentioned it to the speakers we were
walking to lunch is SB 84 is in
your committee and to retain it
for now and then we as the committee
put the put it put a new SB 84 together
with all the things that come out of our
our commission right here out of our
committee oh my God Commission
uh and what we want to see in in 84
basically got it and rebuild it the way
we want to see it because we can't I
mean Senate hijacks our bills so
turnabouts fair play
so let's be ready for you okay well you
might want to just
yeah or yeah so so the the immediate
action would be to convince the the
chair and the committee members to
retain
retain SB 84 so that would give us an
opportunity to to play with it rather
than just pass it or or kill it
it's in this it comes out of the Senate
so I don't know
the sponsors are
or like you said yes Janet's the ranking
member of the uh
or you're the ranking member right or
Legend
so so
another task for you take a look at that
and find out who the sponsors are and
What needs how what's what's the
likelihood of of them voting to retain
and then we and then we also get the uh
who's uh the speaker working on it too
who's chair all right Greg
that's a piece of cake so you and Grace
piece of cake need to Marshall that over
to a pain motion they can retain it easy
she got she got three members right
there I'm trying to convince Greg to
retain it
yeah but let's I think for us all to
look into it and and then be able to
talk about it right yeah you know next
time we meet yeah yeah because that's
that's what we're trying to do is figure
out what we want to do and next meeting
we can talk about it having a little a
little bit of research so uh so I'd like
to ask you also take a look at your
calendars again
so when you when we come back again on
the uh on the 17th you come back with
what the dates going forward are I I
hope we're not working over the summer
but at least take this look at the
calendar taking us into June let's you
know look at it to the end of the
session when we would normally uh end
this session end of June so between now
and the end of June what other are there
any dates
that are bad for you that you'd like to
exclude from consideration otherwise
we'll we'll stay on this uh Monday
Memorial Day is not going to work well
because that's a Monday right so that by
default that's another one
yeah representative I was wondering when
you're talking about the subcommittees
possibly
to be thinking ahead for next week
um
so you're imagining like a process-based
subcommittee every time and then you
want us to be thinking about
for the other companies you know taking
20 existing and basically vetting them
for whether it's overlap where there's
redundancies is that unless it's a
better way yeah no I just want to make
sure I understand because where I want
to think about putting my energy for
those so okay yeah we're making our own
rules
and then we can figure out how we want
to do it yeah
yeah and and like I said I'd like to and
it's I think it's okay for us to
identify those so-called sacred cows
and and put and put a fence around them
and let's just you know this one you
know this one's really important to Matt
and he's he's got to have this
commission and he really wants it to go
forward and we need to work on it
so let's not mess with it let's let's I
like the idea of a template or a
checklist kind of you know going forward
if someone's considering requesting that
you know you should have a Sunset date
in there you should have never remember
usually you know so the guard rails that
we want people to think about right
place would be really helpful I think
right and
I know it didn't get a good read from
the panel but I I'm not ready to let go
of the the thought also of putting a
little more responsibility on committee
chairs
to say if you if
that if we took the commissions and
mapped them all into committee chairs
and said you're a committee chair you
get these 27 commissions
and you need to need to look up look
over the over the shoulder of these
commissions and decide you know are they
going in the right direction do they
need help do they need
to be killed or to be encouraged or
whatever the action is that I think I
personally I think we let the cheers off
too easily on those commissions well it
sounds like yes at the end of the day
they can't necessarily you know strike
anything down or whatever but to just
sort of have the oversight or the the
guidance of someone following up with
these but you're saying where things
stand or well maybe we should even be
going forward even in the in the process
mentality yeah uh that if
the the members of a committee want a
commission are considering a bill and
they're thinking about tipping it in the
direction of a committee or commission
that the chair should have some guidance
for them saying yeah you know we really
don't want to add another commission
let's see if we can work it out with a
subcommittee right here now and not add
it to the to the uh to the bureaucracy
of a commission I feel like At first
sorry the last thought I feel like At
first blush it doesn't seem unreasonable
to you to you know request if somebody
decides their Bill's not going to get
through and they're going to ask for a
commission that they'd have to serve on
that commission right potentially I know
that came up for discussion or not even
just the study committee and I I also
wonder as I guess I'm probably the
newest legislator at this table I
imagine if if newer elected reps
understood that they might be expected
to serve on committees or commissions I
don't think that's entirely clear or
expected right now and that might give
people a reason to think more I think
expectations
the uh
the fact that uh
let's go to we'll go to you now I I
really lost my train of thought that's
okay so
I think when
when we talk about the chairs you know
authority to be able to establish a
subcommittee or a working group or
whatever it is within the committee
structure I like that a lot I also
um am concerned about uh some issues
actually getting
you know the chair to sign off on it and
say yes this is something that's
important so I think as we think about
I'm really looking out for my my friends
on the other side of the aisle because I
know you'll be in the minority in 2024
and so just how do we how do we retain
the ability right to for the minorities
you have to be non-political right
that's exactly it well and so it's like
so is it is it thinking about the
ranking member and their their ability
to you know say hey this is something
that you know should get some uh some
attention but we don't need to create a
study committee or a study Commission on
this
um that could be helpful I also think
and I was I mentioned this to the
speaker in the hallway earlier you know
it could be that
I don't know what the mechanism would be
it could be a resolution that the house
passes because they may not get the
majority of folks on that committee to
say yes this is important but they could
get the votes on the floor of the house
it could be a resolution to say hey
we're gonna uh ask the education
committee to study
um you know higher ed some some
particular topic and then that that's
that's the voice of the entire chamber
saying yes this is something that uh
should should be uh followed up on there
should be action taken to study great
idea yeah
okay that's good sounds good any input
from our assistants
yes
how about 84 and uh 1449
it's in the binder okay
okay and it looked like we were just
looking at the um here it is at the
hearing schedule and it I think 84
that was the center here great okay so
it hasn't been scheduled yet in light
Jasmine
next week okay great all right
do you know um do you have the date and
time it's not on the website yet
which day
okay great thank you on the house on the
house calendar
it's already been heard in the Senate it
pat
they pass it over to us oh it's already
it's passed over it got crossed over
guys
right
anything else any other further business
that we want to uh talk to while we're
here
otherwise we'll see you all on Monday
thank you all for for coming I
appreciate it and hopefully we'll get uh
you said here uh he's missing
and I think Karen will be back soon
Karen told me ahead of time she's been
making sense
foreign